over the past few months volatility has
ruled the markets here's the S&P 500 on
Thursday June 11 when the index fell 6%
in a single day of trading it was a
rough day but not for everyone this
chart from the same day shows the price
of you vxy a fund that's tied to market
volatility you can see as the S&P
tumbled you vxy gained this fund is a
type of volatility trade which is a kind
of bet that has lately attracted more
investors and critics
analysts say volatility trading doesn't
only benefit from market turbulence it
can actually make the swings bigger
which could make markets riskier for
everyone we'll explain
to understand volatility trading a good
place to start is the CBOE Volatility
Index or the VIX the VIX is known as
Wall Street's fear gauge and it
basically measures market volatility and
it's based on options prices tied to the
sp500 the VIX tracks the price of calls
and puts which are contracts that allow
investors to bet on whether stocks will
rise or fall when a lot of investors are
expecting big swings that demand can
drive up the price of calls and puts for
example on March 16 the VIX rose by 43%
a huge jump that led the index to a
record close so on March 16 the market
crashed no stocks had one of the worst
days in history investors were reaching
for options contracts throughout the day
driving up the prices of those options
contracts because they expected more
volatility in the future and that drove
the VIX up now on that day traders were
not only betting on which way stocks
would go
they were also betting on which way the
VIX would go that's a type of volatility
trade but there are others too in fact
there's a whole ecosystem of trading
products that allow investors to bet on
how rough or calm the markets will be
experts say these bets and the hedging
traders do to cover them could be
affecting the market in really big ways
so volatility started out as a metric to
measure the market but now we're seeing
these products that trade volatility and
the whole host of derivatives to trade
volatility getting so big that some
analysts say that they can actually
influence the market and drive more
volatility this current stretch of
market swings comes after a decade of
increased interest in this type of
trading here's a look at assets and
hedge funds that trade market turbulence
and here are assets under management for
exchange-traded products tied to the VIX
like the uvx y-you can see the
volatility business took off after the
financial crisis and grew from there as
bankers devised new and risky ways to
trade it both charts mark 2020 as a
record high it's been crazy
few months for the stock market and
we've seen some of the biggest swings
we've ever seen in history and what
that's done is actually that's drawn
more interest to these types of trades
the volatility trades that means people
are putting more money in these
exchange-traded products that bet on
volatility for some investors and hedge
fund managers the strategy has paid off
one investor I spoke to his strategy's
up more than 200 percent through Mary
while the S&P 500 has fallen over that
timeframe remember you vxy here it is
for the full year and this is the spike
we showed earlier you vxy has had some
big gains but not everyone has one there
have also been big downward moves
leaving some investors with huge losses
we saw just this year professional
investors and professional hedge funds
at rate volatility
some of them took some really big losses
or shut down entirely look you know
these are really risky strategies and
it's important for investors to proceed
with a ton of caution because it's
definitely not a guaranteed win for you
to bet on market volatility and even
some of the most successful and
sophisticated investors can have trouble
with these trades because it can be
really difficult to manage the risk
associated with derivatives trading it's
unclear how long this current bout of
market turbulence will last but experts
agree on something the more volatile
market is also a riskier one
[Music]